da sind wir wieder nach unserer kleinen
osterpause ich hoffe sie hatten auch
schöne feiertage
was lag da dem körbchen ja dasselbe wie
letztes jahr
also fasst noch einmal zusammen was
passiert ist seit angela merkels oster
ruhe waterloo es gab sehr viele
wortmeldungen konsequentes durcheinander
gelaber und ein echtes machtwort bei
anne will
wichtig ist auch und das wollte ich
ihnen sagen ich werde jetzt nicht
tatenlos 14 tage zu sehen und es
passiert nichts was wirklich auch eine
trendumkehr verspricht so ansage von
ganz oben ich werde nicht die nächsten
14 tage tatenlos zusehen
ja diese 14 tage enden moment übermorgen
was ist denn seitdem in der
angelegenheit konkret unternommen worden
genau nichts absolut nichts bundesländer
und kanzler am streiten stadt leben zu
retten über verfahrensfragen wann sie
sich treffen soll oder ob überhaupt noch
montags gipfel heute abgesagt weit und
breit kein plan in sicht wären denn mehr
kompetenzen für den bund die lösung wäre
dann glaubt dass wenn die
bundeskanzlerin nur richtig durchgreifen
kann besiegen wir die pandemie der irrt
ich weiß auch nicht ob frau merkel dann
gegebenenfalls panzer ins saarland
schicken will
der erste vernünftige vorschlag seit
wochen meine damen und herren
wie schlimm wird die dritte welle
frühestens nächste woche haben wir
wieder verlässliche bewohner zahlen da
nur die hälfte der gesundheitsämter über
die feiertage meldet und zwar weil gott
will es so keine ahnung sicher ist seit
der gescheiterten oster ruhe ist die
zahl der korona intensivpatienten um ein
drittel gestiegen ein drittel
es war ein historischer fehler der
länderchefs anfang märz mitten ins
exponentielle wachstum rhein zu lockern
wirklich ein historischer fehler jetzt
sagen sie wir können so nicht
weitermachen
verraten uns aber auch nicht wie
stattdessen hat überhaupt noch irgendwie
eine idee und deshalb glaube ich
brauchen wir einen brücken lockdown
wir müssen die brücke hin zu dem
zeitpunkt wo viele menschen geimpft sind
noch einmal bauen die so noch einmal
es gab noch gar keinen zeitpunkt wo hier
schon viele menschen die impfung wird
ausgebaut
und wenn sie zu hause sich jetzt fragen
wie ist der typ bloß auf den genialen
namen gekommen
der ist ihm tatsächlich ganz spontan an
seinem schreibtisch eingefallen wirklich
er saß da so der laschet und wie könnte
man das nennen warten mal wie lampen
locker und warum oder oder nähen hatte
red eagle lockdown ist auch bescheuert
dann hat er aus dem fenster geguckt
brücken lockten wieder im jahren ist das
denn
ja so ist das entstanden wenigstens mal
ein neuer lockdown name reaktionen der
anderen ministerpräsidenten zwei haben
gesagt ja kann man machen muss aber
nicht vom rest kam entweder aggressives
desinteresse oder offene himmel vom
metaphern alarm im tv mal ganz zu
schweigen
wie lange müsste diese brücke sein die
brücke wo soll die enten sehe ich das
andere ufer und wie weit ist es weg oder
wie viele brücken müssen wir eigentlich
noch gehen eine brücke zum rettenden
ufer wird sie so schnell gebaut wie die
wichtige autobahnbrücke über die a1 bei
leverkusen so ein schönes wort brücke
[Applaus]
lied über sieben lockt downs muss zu
gehen armin laschet hatte angekündigt
über ostern intensiv nachzudenken
auch angela merkel denkt über neue
maßnahmen und mehr kompetenzen für den
bund nach sie denken alle nach das
erinnert mich an dieses kinderbuch
kennen sie das
frederik denkt lieber nochmal nach
frederik die regierungs maus sitzt
nachdenklich auf seinem steigen die
wissenschafts mäuse rufen panische
frederik jetzt wo die zahlen noch leicht
steigen können wir mit härteren
maßnahmen die dritte welle verhindern
gute idee darüber denke ich mal
ausführlich nach wochen später frederik
denkt immer noch nach und die
wissenschafts mäuse sind wütend frederik
du vollidiot exponentielles wachstum zu
endlich was ja oder ich denke dass noch
mal durch und meld mich bei euch nach
ostern
denn wenn ich zu harte maßnahmen
verhängen gehen ja noch mehr dürfe zudem
quer mäusen nach ostern zwei drag trifft
auf der straße zufällig zwei intensiv
mäuse neue pfleger wir wollen euer
ostern und dann haben ihnen die intensiv
mäuse ganz furchtbar verhalten
ende ganz ehrlich wenn ich da drosten
wäre oder die frau bringt man ich würde
die gar nicht mehr beraten
totale zeitverschwendung seit ende
letzten jahres spätestens seit dezember
haben wissenschaftler der politik
gebetsmühlenartig erklärt was damit bei
117 mit der mutante auf uns zukommt
gebetsmühlenartig war viele von denen
sind argumenten ja gar nicht mehr
zugänglich ich will auch gleich sagen
geschenkt jeder der behauptet ist hätte
man alles schon vor acht wochen wissen
müssen also mit sowas will ich wirklich
auseinandersetzen mit fakten nur kein
bock mehr auf fakten
volker bouffier überklebt übrigens auch
immer diese nervigen warnen lämpchen in
seinem auto verbraucht die ganz
deutschland ist jetzt übersät mit
sogenannten modellstädten das komplette
saarland hat sich selbst zum modell
bundesland erklärt die idee öffnen
abgesichert durch tests einigermaßen say
funktioniert das aber nur bei niedrigen
zahlen wegen der nachverfolgbarkeit
macht ja auch sinn heißt ab einer
bestimmten incidents kannst du corona
eben leider nicht weg testen protesten
sollte sich da nicht so eine elite
taskforce kümmern
nach nur drei sitzungen ist die von der
bundesregierung gebildet taskforce text
logistik bereits wieder im ruhemodus die
von den ministern sparen und scheuer
geleitete arbeitsgruppe habe beim
letzten treffen festgestellt dass ihre
aufgabe erfüllt hat und in den standby
modus treten kann
natürlich wahrscheinlich besser so in
großbritannien kriegt übrigens ab heute
jeder bürger jede woche zwei selbsttest
mit der post nach hause geschickt und
bei uns haben in berlin gerade zwei von
sechs impfzentren zugemacht wegen
impfstoffmangel ja auch wegen diesem
anhaltenden schneckentempo kommen wir
möglicherweise einem härteren lockdown
nicht vorbei eine mehrheit der deutschen
fände das laut umfragen okay wenn danach
endlich mal was besser wird derweil
machen die selbst ernannten querdenker
weiter mobil ist ja klar hier letzten
samstag in stuttgart geschätzte 15.000
wie immer ohne abstand ohne masken dafür
mit angriffen gegen journalisten
steinewerfer auf ein ard-team niemand
eingeschritten niemand ein ganz tolles
signal an den rest der ja auch corona
müden bevölkerung ja zum tausendsten mal
man darf auch weiter gegenmaßnahmen
demonstrieren die man unverhältnismäßig
findet das geht doch auch ohne
menschenleben zu gefährden und
vielleicht auch mit ja ein bisschen mehr
distanz zu extremisten ist heute nur
inklusive bewegungen ich war keine
ahnung ob wir jetzt gleich nach hause
fahren und eure frauen oder männer
geprügelt
ob er gewalttätig seien ob ihr euch
kinderpornografisches material anschauen
oder ob er hinter kreuze an die wände
mal das ist mir völlig schnuppe liebe
kinderschänder liebe nazis schön dass
ihr da seid ja auch eher bürgerliche
querdenker oder ehemals bürgerliche
querdenker sehen sich inzwischen als
widerstandskämpfer gegen merkels corona
diktatur weil ja grundrechte ausgesetzt
sind diktatur
was ist da dran herzlich willkommen zu
der heute show diktatur check mit
christian ehring
[Musik]
hallo und heute schicken wir mal ob die
querdenker vielleicht doch recht haben
hat sich unser land in eine diktatur
verwandelt brauchen wir die frage
wirklich ernsthaft stellen ja klar
wie gut ist merkel als diktatur in kann
man auch fragen
mal angenommen du bist diktatoren und
befiehlt eine notbremse aber deine
bundesländer haben keinen bock auf
notbremse so was sagst du dann als
diktator ii und wenn das nicht der fall
ist ein sehr absehbarer zeit dann muss
ich überlegen das ist mein amt sei dass
meine verpflichtung wie kann man das
vielleicht auch bundeseinheitlich und
dort vielleicht ich denke noch nach wenn
die anderen nicht gehorchen dann muss
ich noch mal nachdenken vielleicht das
sind sätze die man von josef stalin eher
selten gehört hat das stimmt ich meine
jeder landrat jeder kreis macht ihr was
er will
kommunen entscheiden allein ob man für
den friseuren test braucht oder nicht da
so ist dass manche diktatoren träumen
von der weltherrschaft merkel träumt
davon eines tages tübingen zu
kontrollieren wieviel diktatur steckt in
der brd hier bilder von der querdenker
demo in stuttgart letzten samstag die
rufen keine diktatur und tatsächlich
geben diese bilder einen entscheidenden
hinweis die polizei geht rückwärts vor
der demo her eselsbrücke in einer
anständigen diktatur würden die beamten
vorwärts laufen und hätten so lange
knüppel in der hand zum bauen
ja und ich meine ist doch gute ehring
unsere polizei hat halt nicht so mit der
gewalt sein also bei linken gegendemos
kann das auch mal anders laufen wie hier
neulich in kassel
nicht schön aber man muss dazu sagen die
antifa frau hatte ein kaputtes rücklicht
notwehr
also jetzt diktatur oder nicht wir sagen
ja noch fakten fakt ist diese diktatur
ist nicht mal in der lage firmen zu
zwingen ihre mitarbeiter zu testen fakt
ist in echten diktaturen wird das
führungspersonal ständig gnadenlos
gefeuert oder eingesperrt aus der
regierung merkel kann man gar nicht
rausfliegen man spricht auch vom
montessori kabinett also ohne jetzt
jemanden konkret zu meinen nur so
allgemein oder lassen sie es mich so
ausdrücken unsere diktatoren müsste
dringend mal ein auslandspraktikum
machen in russland zum beispiel der
russische präsident unterzeichnete ein
gesetz das es ihm ermöglicht bis 2036 an
der macht zu bleiben
2036 die merkel schafft nicht mal bis
oktober und geht dann freiwillig
erbärmlich fazit wenn das hier eine
diktatur ist dann reden wir wirklich von
der offiziell schlechtesten diktatur der
welt sowie für heute und nächste woche
vergleichen wir münchen und myanmar wo
ist es schlimmer ich bin so gespannt
christian der heute-show diktatur check
[Musik]
als diktatur üben wir offensichtlich
noch es gibt sie aber die guten
nachrichten es gibt sie noch da draußen
die spargelsaison ist gerettet wissen
sie noch im letzten jahr ist ja ein teil
des weißen goldes pandemie bedingt auf
den feldern verrottet schlimm
zum glück hat die politik inzwischen
reagiert denn spargel ist in diesem land
offensichtlich alternativlos warum
eigentlich
gernot hassknecht erklärt das deutsche
kulturgut spargel in 151 sekunden so und
heute wage ich den ultimativen tabubruch
kritik am deutschland spargel wie es mir
egal ich ziehe das jetzt durch auch wenn
ich danach das land verlassen muss
spargel wir total überschätzt die leute
sind besessen von dem albino pimmel
gemüse alle teil meter kommt einem
irgendeinen nachbarin entgegen
mein mann und ich hatten schon damals
halt die schnauze interessiert keine sau
jeder dorf drängt einem seine schweine
weisheiten auf
bis die quietsche ist das zeichen dafür
dass der spargel total frisches wirklich
ich dachte der krieg vor angst weil du
ihm fingers deutschlands gemüsebauern
gönne ich alles aber es wird zu viel
geschäft gemacht wegen spargel
der bundestag soll jetzt abstimmen ob
ausländische spargel helfer 102 statt 70
tage sozialversicherungsfrei ausgebeutet
werden dürfen das parlament hat bei
kroner nichts mehr zu melden aber beim
spargel oder hier julia klöckner
unsere bundes nestlé tula ihr
ministerium sorgt nicht dafür dass die
armen rumänen und gloria die den
faserigen quatsch aus der erde polen
nicht mehr zehn tage in quarantäne
sollen sondern nur noch 5 in arbeits
quarantäne
während der sie schon daher der name
arbeiten dürfen wenn die kroko das
impfen mit der gleichen energie
vorantreiben würde wie die spargelernte
wäre inzwischen schon mein hamster
kämpft und zwar mit brillanter und jetzt
sage ich den einen satz der mich die
karriere kostet das schmeckt nicht bei
der spanien schmeckt nur wenn man
hollandaise darüber gibt aber alles
schmeckt wenn man hole und denkst
darüber gibt
hier eine zusammengerollte zeitung schön
schnauze drüber na ja genau die
zuschauer mittlerweile fast alle
versteckten symbole bei uns im neuen
studio gefunden
die illuminati freimaurer staatsführung
ist alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
erst bei so vielen abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten